crainte de reprendre les transports en
commun nouvelles pistes cyclables pour
aller au travail
tout est réuni pour booster les ventes
de vélos à assistance électrique
mais si les ventes sont dopées avec la
crise sanitaire les français montrait
déjà un intérêt croissant pour cet engin
l'année dernière il s'est vendu 380
mille cent vélos à assistance électrique
c'était 12,1 pour cent de plus qu'en
un vélo qui se démocratise pourtant à la
base souvenez-vous les vélos électriques
c'était surtout des trouvailles de géo
trouvetou dans ces deux tubes là nous
avons mis les batteries relayée en trail
par un circuit
mais au delà du côté technique il y
avait une philosophie derrière cette
invention l'arche yves date de 1995 et
sanglots gens du prophétique
je sens que j'ai mis le doigt sur un jeu
quelque chose qui est quasiment vital
actuellement pour nos villes malgré tous
ces arguments le vélo électrique est
trop lourd trop cher et n'arrive pas
vraiment à s'implanter
il faudra attendre le milieu des années
2000 pour qu'il commence à séduire les
français
plus léger plus abordables les ventes
s'envolent passant de 6000 vélos vendus
en 2006 à 388 1100 l'année dernière
pourtant le prix reste un frein exemple
en 2010 le prix peut effectivement
présenté un obstacle important
deuxième obstacle c'est le garage où je
garde mon vélo électrique le soir
puisque je les prix des vélos -l'un
autour d'eux on va dire autour de 1000
euros il faut effectivement pouvoir les
parquer dans un endroit sécurisé en 2017
le gouvernement accorde une aide à
l'achat pouvant aller jusqu'à 200 euros
de quoi booster les ventes en un mois
plus de quinze mille français en
profiter du bonus dans ce magasin les
ventes ont décollé de 20% aujourd'hui
des régions ou des agglomérations met
aussi la main au portefeuille
il vaut mieux car le prix moyen des
vélos à assistance électrique augmente
en 2019
il était de 1749 euros
[Musique]